[Musik]
wir sind ein times square und das ist
unglaublich lange unruhig da also für
die broadway ganzen definitiv nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und natürlich die ganz clans und alles
ist natürlich eine damals kein glück
hatte
[Musik]
wegen des corona virus ist alles tot
alles zu im moment ist das new york dass
ich sehe in new york das angst hat
[Musik]
ich nehme diese maske weil mein vater
draußen firmen gehen und wegen des
corona virus eine maske tragen muss wir
wohnen in new york und new york ist
einer der meist kontaminierten staaten
in amerika und die regierung von new
york will dass ihr masken tragen zurzeit
tragen alle leute eine maske und wir
müssen uns gut schützen damit wir nicht
krank werden
die korona krise ist anfang märz in new
york angekommen
seither müssen die new yorker zu hause
bleiben
die metropole wurde sozusagen
geschlossen die schulen werden
frühestens im september wieder geöffnet
1,1 millionen kinder müssen sich an
fernunterricht gewöhnen die stadt die
immer wach war ist im tiefschlaf
[Musik]
ok
eine stadt wie new york die bernerin
eliane brechbühl ist anfang februar in
new york angekommen um im mount sinai
spital für ihren master in nanomedizin
zu forschen
dann kam das khroma virus traf die
metropole mit voller wucht und änderte
alles
während eliane gegen kubik 19 kämpft
müssen die new yorker zu hause bleiben
und sich auf leute wie david ko sie
verlassen die ihnen nun das essen
bringen
der 36-jährige fahrradkurier ist den
würde aufgewachsen heute lebt er in
kriens vor den corona virus habe ich
eine ausbildung an der new yorker
universität gemacht
angefangen mit produzenten und
regisseuren zu arbeiten das war mein
beruf seit ich hier 2013 angekommen dann
hat die korona krise begonnen und ich
habe alles verloren
ich konnte plötzlich nicht mehr arbeiten
und meine zukunft war ungewiss weil man
nicht wusste wann das enden wird
also habe ich mir gesagt ich muss einen
job finden und weiter genug zu verdienen
ein freund hat mir von postmail erzählt
das ist eine firma die lebensmittel nach
hause liefert als kuriere dürfen hier im
land arbeiten genau wie die
krankenschwestern wie die polizei oder
die feuerwehr
wir sind vermutlich die einzigen die im
moment noch raus dürfen
ich sagte mir okay warum nicht jeden
zweiten tag fährt da wippten kusi mit
der u-bahn von seinem haus in queens
nachbarn hatten
er liefert lebensmittel und andere
sachen die zu hause blockierte new
yorker online bestellen
am anfang habe ich nicht wirklich ans
risiko gedacht weil uns niemand gesagt
hat wie tödlich das virus ist der
präsident meinte im fernsehen es sei wie
eine normale grippe
deshalb dachte ich okay wenn ich
aufpassen kann ich weiter arbeiten
ich habe erst allmählich gemerkt wie
gefährlich es ist als ich die reaktion
der leute gesehen habe seit dem anfang
der krise kannst du die dankbarkeit in
den augen der leute sehen
es ist als würde man ihr leben retten
hallo schön dich zu sehen geht es dir
gut ja hast du keine angst vor dem
corona will muss deshalb hast du eine
maske ich brauche das geld
nach wochenlangen ausgangssperren
fordert die korona virus krise
allmählich ihren tribut und trifft vor
allem arme allein in den ersten wochen
der krise haben in new york 1,2
millionen menschen ihre arbeit verloren
in new jersey haben sich im ersten monat
718.000 menschen arbeitslos gemeldet
ohne es zu einem echten problem geworden
für viele amerikaner die sich ihre miete
und lebensmittel nicht mehr leisten
können
einige leute haben sich entschlossen zu
helfen hat die todeslager von hätten
überlebt
wir werden lebensmittel und vorräte an
menschen liefern die sie brauchen
ich habe vor vielen jahren niemanden
gerettet
die erkennt einen anderen mann und der
kann angeblich so viel hühnchen
rindfleisch und steak sorgen also werde
ich heute 600 von lebensmittel und
kisten von toilettenpapier und
papiertüchern abholen
das alles werden die leute geben die es
brauchen ich werde vorne paten in dieses
zeug ist viel zu viel wert
ja
[Musik]
sein cousin stand damals vor gericht es
ging um eine schusswaffe und ich habe
ihn gerettet menschen erinnern sich
daran wer ihnen geholfen hat als sie am
ende war ich habe auch noch papiertücher
hallo auch die klopapier ja das brauchen
wir auch die einzigen menschen die man
in den leeren straßen noch sieht sind
fahrradkuriere wie david für die 25.000
restaurants und bars die in new york
city geschlossen worden sind ist die
korona krise eine katastrophe so auch
für das berühmte schweizer kaffee select
in sowie eines von drei restaurants die
dem zürcher musikproduzenten oliver
sturm gehören
vor acht jahren verlor und somit gibt es
nur zwei werk zum beruf machen will das
haben nicht abschlüsse das einfach neben
dem sagen oder ich musste nur eine träne
die schmidt vor allem schlag auf den
anderen sie aber in der bald also da wir
sind fast stündlich
mit der öffnung mit aus unternehmen und
ganz zu machen und dann halt ganz zurück
macht man hat sofort mit serie chinesin
willkommene und sehr viel geld gute und
dass gott wollen sie nicht schnell und
hat somit angestellt sofort entlang
sofort so schnell wie möglich haben
arbeitslose nimmt also jedes restaurant
hat wahrscheinlich ein schotte vor
nur schon vor der auswahl von
frischwaren konto 10 bis 15 0 toren oder
hat einfach mit sofort würden noch fünf
sagte boris vorjahres schrieb analyst
roger das letztere nimmt sich vom kaffee
select braucht 100 bis 150 tue sich
offenbar konto sondern überhaupt türen
aufmachen
ich bin willens schulden zu um eine
wiedereröffnung vor den restaurants zu
machen
aber zuerst müsste ich mit hausbesetzern
sitzen und es wird sich nicht wieder so
handeln wie vorher 20 hat den stillstand
gemacht ich glaube
menschheit wirklich in den nächsten paar
jahren oder für immer
[Musik]
ja da jetzt einfach zu sagen monika und
die schweiz und so eine sache wo man
sich erinnere schweiz und falls
situation wo mir nehme werde durch
machen dann kann ich natürlich nicht
verkaufen da ihnen selbst war der ex
trainer - machen inzwischen mit
interessierten kunden hält oder so das
heißt machen einfach so laufen und das
ist sexy
[Musik]
mein statement ist dass man muss alles
in frage stellen
man muss alles neue offen man muss wenn
man eine dass die stadträte darin dass
einzeln oder als kleiner betrieb und
probieren sich wieder neue aufzuarbeiten
und neue waldarbeiter wo funktioniert
für normalsterbliche
[Musik]
nirgendwo in new york city ist die
korona krise sichtbarer als am broadway
und auf dem times square
normalerweise besuchen hunderttausende
den times square und tausende weitere
bevölkern die legendären theater am
benachbarten broadway aber an dem tag an
dem ihr die schauspielerin sängerin und
immobilienmaklerin zu mathys aus
küssnacht treffen ist der times square
absolut leer
noch
weil
dass ich es gibt sie und sich mama aus
ein unzerstörbares sogenannte statement
hat wo die entwicklung und sich ein
wunderbarer charakter will sie einfach
so es ist so ein niveau das tor fliegt
und zeit und mehr geld nicht und es
passt sehr gut zu dem dieser zudem zum
einsatz um den new yorker überlappen
[Musik]
sie haben jetzt das neue zubehör
gestellt das auf ständig tätig und
arbeitslosengelder beziehen
ich kann mich abmelde ich weiß noch
nicht ob ich qualifiziert wie möglich
wiederkommen
aber ich hoffe sehr wenig um also ich
muss sagen das ist immer immer aber
nicht unbekannt das habe ich auch in
meinem früheren regen beruf oder eine
tiger brewer von immer häufiger im
theater sehr viel immer wieder habe dass
man an einem punkt wo man sein wie
geht's weiter
und ich bin danach reagiert ev massen
und professionelle von theater heißt das
schon
man muss man muss jetzt flexibel in
italien mit sorge wie sich alles
verändert
aufgrund von dem was passiert war
irgendwie immer weiß wie mit dem umgang
zwischen nun je aktie oder und flexibel
bleiben und aufpassen
hamilton läuft es ist einfach eine neue
große broadway hits und
suter und dosé kotina
[Musik]
so begann
[Applaus]
das ist natürlich heartbreaking
mandelsons widerruft und nachher nach
der pause jetzt für mich hat das immer
ein ort wo man ihn inspirieren und die
stadt braucht passt wie brauchen
ermutigung im leben was schwierig ist
ratlos ist ein stadt oder in der nähe
des times square befindet sich das un
hauptquartier
es ist seit wochen geschlossen hier
arbeitet die baslerin mirian us
politiker wenn sie nicht nur
entwicklungsprogramme vor ort leitet
das konzert findet ist statisch geduldig
die verstopfung und glauben es geht
darum abstürzte
vor allem die betroffenen sich und ihre
krise wie viele gestorben sind und wie
schneidet das jetzt blöd abruf kauften
und seiten jetzt löst gewinnt vor allem
innovativ und solidarisch gesammelt
deutschland braucht hat fürs spital 1000
nahe grenoble geklatscht
eine von harnos lebensmittellieferungen
ist für fortuna wie es die mexikanische
einwanderin wohnt gegenüber von einem
der krankenhäuser die am stärksten
betroffen sind stakes und begas kennen
sie berlin
für jüdische menschen dort sei mit dir
ich kann nicht raus weil ich zwei
töchter habe und ich liebe meine töchter
ich liebe sie
also sage ich mir wenn ich mich mit der
krankheit anstecke wohin werden meine
töchter dann gehen
ich habe nichts mehr alles was ich noch
habe brauche ich für die miete für alles
andere habe ich gar nichts mehr so viele
patienten werden hier hergebracht tag
und nacht ich gehe ins badezimmer und
sehe die krankenwagen die ankommen immer
wieder manchmal zwei drei krankenwagen
auf einmal er habe panik
[Musik]
die lage ist weiterhin schlimm heute war
einer der schwierigsten tage meines
lebens
wir haben heute viel tod gesehen vor der
korona krise arbeitete jason chen als
spezialist für lungenerkrankungen in
einer privatpraxis jetzt leitet er die
intensivstation eines krankenhauses in
der umgebung von new york die machen
eine wunderbare arbeit danke unsere
intensivstation ist frei ich war noch
nie in meinem leben so müde
wir haben hier schon viele grippe
ähnliche krankheiten behandelt und auch
corona wären aber ich habe noch nie eine
krankheit gesehen die sich so schnell
verbreitet wie diese kollegen werden bei
uns eingeliefert
enge freunde familienmitglieder
natürlich hat man da auch angst um sich
selbst new york hat so viele tote dass
die stadt sich entschließen musste
einige der opfer des corona virus in
massengräbern auf haarteilen zu begraben
auf dieser berüchtigten insel in der
bronx fanden schon über eine million
namenlose leichen ihre letzte ruhe
darunter opfer der spanischen grippe von
1918 und der aids epidemie
[Musik]
nicht weit entfernt von haarteilen tim
mount sinai spital versucht medien zu
verstehen wieso das corona virus so
tödlich ist
[Musik]
im labor machen
womit minute stelle interessieren und
der kontext mit kombinierter ist dass
die meisten komplikationen von einem
videos vom minute vom büro sauber
sondern vor überreaktion vom immunsystem
und mit dieser nanopartikel approbierte
mitarbeiten überreaktion immer im moment
sehr viel in vitro sache
das heißt etwa mit sauer- und lavieren
reaktion
[Musik]
während die new yorker weiter zu hause
bleiben müssen kämpft eliane auch heute
gegen das virus es ist ein ganz
besonderer tag für sie
[Musik]
unglaublich es ist zu amerikanisch
der tag neigt sich dem ende zu der abend
wird anstrengend für david er macht eine
lieferung nach der anderen
diese nacht sieht gut aus so verdient
man geld während der korona krise macht
seine letzte lebensmittellieferung in
einem piano laden magst du state is to
stay
ihr seid drei nicht wahr
[Applaus]
[Musik]
morgen wieder hier morgen wieder hier um
den kampf zu führen um leben und seelen
zu retten
[Musik]
es ist 19 uhr
wie an jedem tag seit dem beginn der
krise klatschen die new yorker um diese
zeit für das krankenhauspersonal und die
rettungssanitäter
[Musik]
new york könnte monate oder sogar jahre
brauchen um sich von der pandemie zu
erholen
new york und dem es früher hieß es habe
nie geschlafen ist und bleibt eine
unverwüstliche statt
die irgendwann wieder aufstehen wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]